-Our next guest
is a very funny comedian
who kicks off her Deal With It
tour September 16th
at the Pantages Theatre
in Minneapolis.
Please welcome to the show
Taylor Tomlinson.
♪♪
[ Applause ]
-Thank you so much
for being here.
-Oh, my gosh.
Thank you for having me.
♪♪
-Thank you so much.
I'm so happy to have you
here in person.
And I'm also happy --
You're from California,
but you now are spending time
living in New York, as well.
How you are finding New York?
-I am.
You know, I miss my car a lot.
I'm used to driving --
Like, I miss crying in a car
that I'm driving.
-Sure.
-Like, here can you do it,
but you're like, "Oh, my God.
I'm not in control of my life
or even this vehicle."
-[ Laughs ]
-It's very triggering.
But, yeah, my boyfriend
lives in New York and is, like,
born and raised in Manhattan,
which I consider
low-key child abuse, but...
[ Laughter ]
...he's like, "If I have kids,
we have to raise them here,"
and I was like,
"I'm gonna love my children."
[ Laughter ]
But I've learned that, like,
when you are single,
and you're looking for somebody,
like, you need to make a list
of all the things you want
in a partner, right?
'Cause if you forget
to put something on there,
the universe is like, "Well,
technically, you didn't say,
so we didn't bring you that."
And because he grew up
in New York, he cannot drive.
Didn't even know
I had to ask for that.
Thought that kind of just
came with the fully grown man.
[ Laughter ]
And let me be clear.
He could drive, but he won't.
-Oh.
-He, like, won't drive, because
he's like, "I'm a New Yorker."
Like, you know what I mean?
-Yeah, I do.
-I'm like,
"What are you gonna do
if there's, like,
an apocalypse?"
And he's like, "There are Lyfts,
there are Ubers."
I'm like, "What do you think
Uber drivers are gonna be doing
during the apocalypse?
You think they're gonna be
hopping on the app, like,
'Oh, hell yeah, surge pricing.
Must be 'cause Satan's here.'"
Like, it's just crazy to me.
-You -- when I saw
Quarter-Life Crisis,
your special on Netflix --
And I feel this is something
that is true of me
as I get older.
I become very resentful
of young talented people.
And I was like, "How is she
so good, so young?"
And then I felt
a little bit better,
because you started very young
doing stand-up in churches.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I started when I was 16.
That's the only place
you can do stand-up
when you're 16 is in church.
-Uh-huh.
-And only if you do
an altar call at the end.
If you end it with like,
"And Jesus died for your sins,"
then they're like,
"Okay. You can do 15.
That's fine."
But, like, comedy clubs
won't let you perform
until you're 18.
-Gotcha.
-And even then,
it's a little sketchy.
-And so what --
And did you find --
Did the material go over well
with your church crowd?
-You know, I spent most
of the first couple years
of my stand-up "career"...
[ Laughter ]
...being, like, very apologetic
for just being so young.
Like, the first joke I ever did,
how I used to open sets,
is I used to say, like, "I know
there's probably gonna be
like a generational gap here.
You know, I'm so young.
Like, you guys saw 'Titanic'
in theaters, I saw it on VHS.
Like, you cried
because Jack died.
I cried because
Leonardo DiCaprio
didn't look like that anymore."
[ Laughter ]
-Would -- so Deal With It
is the new special.
Why are you calling --
The new hour you're touring
with, I should say.
Why is it called Deal With It?
-The new hour that I'm doing now
is a bit darker than
Quarter-Life Crisis was.
Like, Quarter-Life Crisis,
my Netflix special,
is a lot about, like,
being in your 20s
and, like, it sucks
and it's hard
'cause you're in transition.
And this new hour
is, like, getting to the bottom
of why you suck.
Like, "Okay. We know we suck.
Let's figure out what it is,"
with, like, a lot of therapy
and soul searching and whatnot.
So I named the tour Deal With It
because it's, like, dealing
with your issues, dealing
with your childhood trauma.
And also, if you saw
Quarter-Life Crisis
and you come to see me,
and you're like,
"Why aren't there more
dating jokes?"
Deal with it.
This is the show.
-Right.
-This is the show.
-You actually talk about
and went through
what a lot of people did,
which is continuing
to do therapy during a pandemic
where you couldn't
be in the room with someone,
and having to do it over Zoom.
-Mm-hmm.
-How did you find that?
-Well, I started seeing a new
therapist during the pandemic.
My old one,
in one of our last sessions,
told me that
when I get close to people,
I have a tendency
to self-sabotage,
and, like, I thought that was
bull [bleep] so I ghosted her.
[ Laughter ]
And I started seeing my current
therapist during the pandemic.
So I only recently
met her in person.
And, like, oh, man --
Have you done Zoom therapy,
Seth?
-I haven't done Zoom therapy.
-Oh, it's so much fun
watching your trauma buffer.
It's a great time.
Watching your issues
struggle under the weight
of your weak Wi-Fi.
It's really -- it's great.
Every week, I was like,
"It's just hard.
My dad doesn't listen."
She's like, "I can't hear you.
You froze.
If you're still talking,
I'm not getting any of it.
Luckily, I have
your credit-card information.
I'll see you next week."
-You -- we were talking
backstage about the timing.
I felt deeply empathetic
for comedians who maybe --
the shutdown happened right
before they were about to tape.
Like, that's the worst, right?
You have an hour ready to go,
and you have to wait so long.
Your special came out
right before.
And somebody might think,
"Oh, that's bad timing,"
'cause a big special comes out,
you can then go sell tickets.
But it actually turned out
to be pretty good timing.
-Yeah, I mean,
I was very nervous,
because it came out
the week before lockdown.
So just under the wire.
And I was thinking, like,
"Okay. Well, I guess
I missed my moment here."
Like, by the time everything
goes back to normal,
if it ever does, I --
people will have forgotten
that this special even came out.
Meanwhile, my agents
are calling me like,
"This is a great time
to have a special come out."
Like, seriously, people
are trapped in their homes.
They're watching stuff
they wouldn't even consider
watching if they
could go outside.
Like, "People are really giving
stuff a chance right now."
And I'm like, "Okay.
I would have hoped this did well
without a global emergency,
but I'll take it."
-You saying that makes me
realize how many agents
probably told clients, "You are
crushing this pandemic."
-Oh, my God. This one --
"COVID's been great for you."
[ Laughter ]
I heard that so many times.
-I think it's very exciting,
as we do come out of it,
hopefully, that people
will be able to go
and see you perform again.
And you've got a lot
of great tour dates
in a lot of great cities.
And thank you so much
for being here.
It's really lovely
talking to you.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-Taylor's Deal With It tour
starts September 16th
in Minneapolis.